okay then so rx580 well let's cut to the
chase here it's an overclocked rx480 and
well there we go do like and subscribe
to support digital Foundry and I'll see
you next
time all right you want more okay well
let's do
it okay then so AMD calls the top end RX
cards in the 500 series Lis refined and
that's kind of exactly what we're
getting really according to the red team
we are now on third generation 14
nanometer finfet production technology
and that means that we can push the
existing RX 470 and 480 to significantly
higher clocks and of course that means
improved performance RX 580 takes on the
GTX 1060 in both 3 gig and 6 gig forms
okay so let's look at some specs no real
surprises here the 580 is literally
identical in terms of core configuration
to its pressor so we're looking at 36
fourth generation gcn compute units and
yes clock speeds are improved over the
480 the 580 essentially increases the
480s maximum boost clock of 1266 MHz to
about 1340 MHz okay so that's nice but
it's not exactly thrilling but here's
the thing there's not really going to be
a reference 580 instead the likes of
sapphire MSI and Asus can do their own
thing and that means more power for our
Factory overclocks which kind of WI
Wiens the Gap okay so the MSI 580 here
hits almost 1393 MHz while this Sapphire
model that's quite remarkable hitting
1450 megahertz out of the box so yeah I
would say that the 500 series is a bit
more than a Rebrand of the older CS they
really do go quite a bit faster in terms
of clocks at least and well maybe it's a
different story with aftermarket coolers
and whatnot but my reference 480 there's
more chance of me winning the lottery
than there is of this thing hitting 1.45
GHz but to what extent does all of this
actually change the LIE of the land in
terms of the mainstream GPU landscape
okay so in theory even if the reference
480 could sustain Max clocks all of the
time this Sapphire card should
notionally be 15% faster but well
unfortunately it kind of isn't
Assassin's Creed Unity there's only a 7%
uplift dropping to around 2% with the
MSI model here ashes of the singularity
Sapphire card about 99.5% faster the MSI
version again only 2% ahead we do see
better results with Crisis 3 though
Sapphire Powers ahead by around 11%
versus 8.5% on the MSI Edition the
biggest Improvement I could find was
rise of the Tomb Raider the sapphire 580
Powers ahead of the reference 480 by
around 133% the MSI variant by around
10% but you can see the problem here
can't you we're comparing Factory
overclocked 580s to a reference 480 and
the reality is that if we stacked up
Factory overclock versions of both cards
the Gap would close up significantly and
while we are getting higher frequencies
on the 580s there seems to be a LW of
diminishing returns kicking in in terms
of the actual frame rates we're getting
as a result but simply the 580 is
essentially a replacement for the 480
it's not actually a huge Improvement I
mean that's kind of fine actually I mean
fundamentally there's nothing wrong with
the 480 if you subscribe to our Channel
we often run detailed in-game
performance tests where the 480
regularly holds its own against the more
popular GTX 1060 even when the
benchmarks say that Nvidia has the
faster C generally certainly in dx11
titles the reality is that AMD offers
more RAM great performance and a cheaper
price point and now with the release of
the 580 the 480 is essentially a bit
faster and that's okay right I mean yes
but at the same time giving it a new
name makes it sound like it's something
different faster better when the real
life performance is essentially still in
the same ballpark and it's using the
same technology I mean the MSI card here
is much closer to the reference 580 spec
than the sapphire and the minuscule
performance boosts we're seeing against
the 480 in some cases is really sitting
just above the margin of error it is
what it is an rx480 just with uh you
know slight tweaks to the clocks okay
well let's stack up the two 580s I've
got here physically the Sapphire card is
really quite awesome actually actually
and uh yeah it's a very cool design but
man it's quite a unit it's huge and
weighty and has both six pin and 8 Pin
power inputs remember when the RX line
was supposed to be about power
efficiency that seems to have gone out
of the window with this one the MSI
model here has a significantly smaller
thermal solution and only requires one
eight pin power input but I am actually
quite surprised at how the fan needs to
kick in on this card I mean I'm
struggling to think of an MSI gaming
card I've seen in the past isn't
anything other than whisper chir at
stock frequencies so what about the GTX
1060 then well I've only got a reference
card here the founders Edition but the
trend pretty much speaks for itself on
Assassin's Creed Unity the two 580s I
have beat the 3 gig 1060 but the 6 gig
model still a touch faster and the Gap
would probably open up a bit with a
similarly facty overclock 6 gig 1060
however elsewhere in dx11 land AMD does
indeed catch up Crisis 3 sees the MSI
model close the gap with the 6 gig 1060
while the Sapphire card actually pulls
ahead of bit The Witcher 3 is faster but
only by a nose and remember that factory
OC's are in place on the red side but
the point is that overall we're
competitive Far Cry Primal is
interesting in that both 580s hand in
identical scores but we're still doing
well against the GTX 1060 here good
stuff now with dx12 things get more
interesting I've switched the division
to its DX 12 render for our benchmarks
now and both of the 580s are at least
10% faster than the GTX 1060 now Nvidia
has recently revamped its dx12 driver
resulting in better performance on ashes
The Singularity and Hitman games that
have traditionally hammered the Pascale
bench results well the 1060 is now on
par with the RX 480 in ashes but the
580s kind of move the goalposts about 7
to 8% faster depending on which card you
measure Hitman dx12 yeah nvidia's done
some work here so again a reference 1060
will beat a reference 480 but the 580s
reclaim performance leadership but check
out what's going on with the 3 gig 1060
there Hitman simply runs out of memory
here resulting in a big performance
downgrade it's like a kind of pitched
battle is taking place in the world of
mainstream GPU benchmarking driver
revisions pushing Up Performance and now
the 500 series inching ahead by virtue
of its frequency bumps but again I think
the main point is that whether we're
talking about 480s 580s or 1060s for the
most part they are pretty much the same
the overall grouping of results is
actually pretty similar overall
especially with dx11 and in this sector
of the market with so many Factory
overclocks in play benchmarking results
will become even more of a blur now
generally speaking personally I find it
really hard to choose between 480 580
and 1060 as a result I'd happily game on
all of them though if I had an older or
less capable CPU the 10 60 would be my
go-to card but with something like a
modern I5 again if you're not really
concerned about power efficiency I think
you'd struggle to tell the difference in
terms of actual gameplay experiences and
I suppose in a way that's good news
they're all great products for 1080p
gameplay and that's awesome but
obviously there is a differential
somewhere along the line so let's talk
power consumption and overclocking and
it's here where we pay the price for the
RX 580s frequency bump the MSI model
actually gets off pretty lightly with an
increase of just 20 watts over the
reference 480 but the superclock
sapphire model here well that adds an
extra 56 watts to hit that tremendous
1450 MHz boost clock I mean it's getting
on for consuming an extra 90 wats there
compared to the reference GTX 1066 gig
card and this is measuring Peak system
load by the way though I have disabled
the i7s overclock for these tests and so
yeah by extension overclocking isn't
great for the Sapphire card I could only
add 10 MHz to the core before it becomes
unstable 10 MHz I think that's a new
record for me in terms of the lack of
overclocking head room on the plus side
though the G5 memory easily hits 9 GB
per second now what the MSI model lacks
in frequency out of the box you can
easily make up via overclocking and I
found that it hit the same maximum 1460
MHz in terms of stable core clocks and
yes the same 9 gbits per second on the 8
gigs of memory so how does that Stack Up
in terms of performance well kind of a
lot of not much to be honest an extra
one to two frames per second and yes
your power consumption is obviously hit
harder so yeah bearing in mind the extra
power and the kind of limited return I'm
not sure if overclocking is worth the
bother to be honest now if you're
looking for a nice overclockable radian
card well the RX 570 is very nice there
but more on that in a later video in the
meantime I'm going to wrap this one up I
mean ultimately the RX 480 was and is a
great card and the rx580 is effectively
the same thing just with a meaty
overclock in place especially the
sapphire nighto model here which really
does push the core kind of kicking and
screaming to its limits but
fundamentally rx580 is not a GameChanger
it's not going to stop GTX 1060
continuing to sell like Gang Busters
even though there's a pretty decent
performance story here and we know that
amd's Vega is coming along really soon
now now personally I would have
preferred to see that launch at the top
end first then scale down to the
mainstream with an RX 580 that does
actually shake up the market just like
the 480 did 10 months ago at the very
least I hope this Polaris relaunch does
at least Propel the RX 570 into the
Limelight I'll be looking at that one
really soon and suffice to say just like
the 470 it is a bit of a winner when it
comes to bang for the buck but that's
all from me for now as always do like
subscribe and consider supporting our
patreon where you can access pristine
quality download versions of all of our
videos but from me for now thanks for
watching